في ازيد من 100 مدينه وبلده اسبانيه خرج
من جديد مئات الالاف من الاسبان للمطالبه
مره اخرى بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار وايقاف
ما يصفونها بالابا الجماعيه في غزه لكن
رغم المواقف الحكوميه الرسميه الاسبانيه
التي طالبت اسرائيل بوقف هذه الحرب ثمت
غضب في اوساط الاف المواطنين الذين
يطالبون الحكومه بخطوات فعليه من بين
هؤلاء هناك الاحزاب التي تؤيد الحكومه
وبطبيعه الحال الوزيره السابقه
يوني ما هي
مطالبكم للاسف اليوم الحكومه الاسبانيه
باتت اقرب للزج بنا في حرب ضد اليمن
وبعيده عن اتخاذ خطوات ملموسه لوقف
الاباده الجماعيه ضد الفلسطينيين نشعر
بقلق كبير ونطالب بان تمتنع اسبانيا عن
المشاركه في القوى البحريه في البحر
الاحمر لانها تهدف لحمايه مسؤول عن جرائم
الاباده الجماعيه وان تدعم الدعوه
القضائيه التي رفعتها جنوب افريقيا ضد
اسرائيل بالاضافه الى هذه المطالب هناك
مطالب اخرى رفعها المتظاهرون اليوم اهمها
ربما هي وقف التبادل التجاري مع اسرائيل
وخاصه تصدير واستيراد الاسلحه المطلب الذي
ذكرته الوزيره ايضا يطالب به المتظاهرون
هنا الذين يقولون ان على اسبانيا ان
تدعم من جديد متابعه اسرائيل قضائيا امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه ايمن زبير الجزيره
مدريد